[Musique]
ça c'est une photo que j'ai pris
moi-même que j'ai simplement imprimé
voilà juste une photo j'ai pas besoin
d'en faire plein on écrit au dos un
petit message donc moi par exemple dans
ma vie j'ai été masseuse donc j'aime
bien offrir à ma mère à massage alors
j'écris pour maman je te une heure de
massage
offert à la maison j'ai acheté une
feuille de papier donc celle-ci c'est un
papier imprimé sur un petit peu épais
avec un
joli grain particulier qui qui est très
naturel et je l'appli moi-même donc
c'est un format A4 tout simple
je l'applique moi-même
donc voilà en fait là c'est comme un
carré ici je vais remonter comme ça et
puis ensuite
je plie une fois
deux fois et le fait que ce soit plié
deux fois c'est une astuce de pharmacien
ça ne bouge plus donc je fais la même
chose de l'autre côté
juste à l'endroit où ça va plier je
déchire sur seulement
l'épaisseur du pli maintenant
quand je ferme là
je referme mon pli par dessus
[Applaudissements]
et là ça bouge pas ensuite je vais
glisser ma carte au dos de laquelle j'ai
inscrit le cadeau de Noël immatériel ça
peut être une sortie au cinéma une place
au théâtre
je la mets dans l'enveloppe
je referme l'enveloppe et j'écris pour
maman de la part de Anna et je mets ça
sous le sapin
[Musique]